all right guys
bang bang i've got edwin here thank you
so much for doing this sir
tom thanks so much for having me
absolutely let's just jump right into it
your background how the hell did you get
started with all of this
kind of work in the short selling world
um so i've always been passionate about
stocks from a really young age like in
second grade i was
consumed with the stock market then
freshman year of college
just by chance i was introduced to two
of the best short sellers out there mark
cahotes who's an individual investor and
short seller
and jim carruthers who runs a short only
fund called sofos
and they became my mentor throughout my
college years
um so so i interned for them for a while
i interned in the sec enforcement
division where i kind of got to see the
other side of corporate malfeasance and
how bad companies operate and now i
write a
newsletter called the barricade where i
talk about corporate wrongdoing
yeah so i got to ask how did you meet uh
those two guys and it seems like you've
got a really good network and i've heard
stories that you are
one of the best networkers in the world
so tell me about how the hell do you
get in touch with those guys and so many
other people
so tom i found there's kind of two
secrets to being good
at meeting people especially when you're
young one is writing online
so you put out a lot of content online i
found if you're just active on twitter
if you write articles if you write blog
posts on seeking alpha and that type of
thing
some people will reach out to you so jim
crawlers who was one of my mentors read
something i wrote and reached out to me
and then the other way is just by being
very persistent and emailing people and
dm'ing people
so i i've cold emailed people five times
in a row not like day after day but like
every week
to try to meet you know when i was
really young sometimes i just show up in
people's offices and ask to talk to them
although that gets weirder as you get
older um
but i just being persistent sometimes
cold calling definitely cold emailing a
lot dming people on twitter
and the thing is when you're young you
have this aurora of innocence so people
don't mind and are much more likely to
talk to you
so that's what i found works pretty well
i love that what's the craziest story
you have as to how you met somebody
i'll i'll i'll give you two one is i
went to
there was a hedge fund in san francisco
everyone said was really smart and you
should talk to them so i email them and
they never respond never respond
i'm in freshman year so i just i just
take the caltrain up there
i go to their offices and i'm like i
wanna i go to the
it's a big building so i gotta go to the
guy guarding elevators i'm like i wanna
speak to someone at this hedge fund
and they're like do you have an
appointment and i said no and he's like
well you can't get in and i'm like
please just ten minutes i have this
report i want to show
and that he's like no way you're getting
it so then i'm in the lobby
and i pull out linkedin and i just start
look up people at the hedge fund and i
just start dming them being like hey i'm
in your lobby right now i'm a freshman
in college
i really like stocks can i get you
something and i dm maybe everyone at
that hedge fund
and one person was like yeah and they
called the person in the lobby they took
me up and i got to go meet
at this hedge fund and you know the
meeting went really well i stayed in
touch and they
and they told me after they thought it
was either a scam or some really
quirky kid and um so that was one crazy
story
and the other crazy one was i cold
emailed bill ackman on a whim
and he met with me for about an hour and
he was wicked smart
and and that one was just normal email
response and
i mean that's that was another big
highlight i love
that so let's talk about short selling
because that's pretty much what you
focus on
uh many people who are listening to this
uh have never heard
anyone kind of on the bear case so
what exactly is short selling and why do
you think it's so important in the
market
so short selling is just betting against
companies there's a few methods you
could do that
actually short selling mechanically is
when you borrow a share of a stock that
somebody owns
you sell it and you promise to return it
at a future date so if you own shares of
apple i might borrow a share from you
sell it for 300. buy it back a month
from now hopefully it's fallen to 200
and return it to you so i sold it for
300 bought it back for 200.
i profit the difference if the stock
falls i pay you a small fee
for the inconvenience um and you make
the difference
on the other hand if you short a stock
and it goes up your losses can be
infinite because you need to buy it back
at a higher price
so that's mechanically how it works and
the reason it's important in the markets
is short sellers are often the ones most
incentivized
to to expose corporate wrongdoing so if
you look at a lot of the big frauds
over the last 20 30 years oftentimes
it's short sellers that were the ones to
dig into the financial statements
talk to ex-employees blow the whistle to
auditors to help get the ball rolling
to expose the fraud so short selling
short sellers are like an important
check
to the system which is usually designed
to prop stocks
stocks up and only highlight good news
short sellers are the ones trying to
expose
wrongdoing and the bad news and
corporate wrongdoing
so that's why they're important and
there's a subset of short sellers called
activist short sellers
which are really aggressive in putting
out detailed 10
20 30 page reports on public companies
where they're bending against
them and they'll put out these detailed
reports to hopefully expose wrongdoing
drive the stock down
and profit off their position against
companies got it and so how did you
think about short selling differently
when you
were working with the sec as an intern
versus beforehand like what were some of
the things that you learned there
or things that maybe other people
wouldn't understand about how the sec
views short selling
so that's a great question so the sec
you know it's a government institution
so everything runs slower
one thing that i didn't fully appreciate
about the sec
is that a lot of what the sec does and
focuses on
comes from external referrals so so i'd
estimate but 90
of what the sec looks at is either
referrals from
stock exchanges through the public
comment and tip
like box on their website their
whistleblower complaints which are taken
really seriously
or from you know calls with sources that
they talk to a lot
very less of the sec is about
like you know there's some of this
actively patrolling the market and
seeing if somebody's doing something
wrong but a lot more is reactive
to external complaints and one of the
sources of external complaints
can be short sellers you know the sec
does have a common
like submission box where anybody can
submit complaints
on a company and short sellers often
i've used that box to submit wrongdoing
and then the sec will have an archive of
all complaints against a company
so when they decide to look into a
company they'll see here's 20 complaints
members of the public have submitted
often the highest quality content is
from short sellers
also there's been a trend more with
chinese companies at least where a short
seller will write a detailed report
on a chinese company that might be
faking financials or inflating
financials
and the scco often launched an
investigation solely off that
or send the report to the company and
ask for a response
i think one example the wall street
journal talked about was
a chinese company called iqe which is
like the netflix of china
got it and so let's start with maybe
kind of one of the reports that you
wrote early on
care.com uh it's extensive uh it's super
thorough
and not only one i think was it well
received by a number of people other
than the company
but two it kind of really launched you
into this world of short selling and
people
uh started paying attention but what
exactly caught your attention about
care.com and kind of what did you
allege in your piece so care.com
was the largest babysitting platform in
the u.s at the time i started
looking into them four years ago they
were publicly traded
um and i had a friend who was a
babysitter on the platform and she had a
really bad experience on the site and
was like hey you should look into them
and when i start looking at a company
the first thing i do
is check a government website called
pacer where you can see lawsuits against
a company and i saw
care.com had been sued four or five
times by parents
who had a really bad experience with
babysitters from the website like they
hired a babysitter who wasn't vetted
or like multiple kids had even died to
care.com babysitters and that was
in litigation against the company so
that's kind of what sparked my interest
and then you know i started to test out
the site's website on my own and they
claimed to be vetting their babysitters
they had on their website
so i tried to sign up as harvey
weinstein on care.com i used
a photo of harvey weinstein the email
harvey the babysitter at gmail.com i
made up all this info
and they like said you consent to a
background check i'm like yeah
and then at the end of the process
they're like we'll like get back to you
in two to three days on whether or not
you're accepted
i said there's no way i'm going to be
accepted to care.com to view babysitters
harvey weinstein
two or three days later they're like
hello harvey you're accepted
and i that's when i knew something was
wrong and i made fake accounts as daffy
duck and donald trump too
and they keep accepting them even though
they said they were vetting people
so that's what really sparked my
interest i put out a little report on
them
exposing these safety issues the stock
fell the company called stanford my
college to complain about
it and stanford met with mean is like
you should take this down and i said no
and i researched them more i filed
public record requests
with all 50 state attorney generals so
it's like filing a foia request with the
state attorney general for consumer
complaints against care.com
and that gave me about 5000 pages of
consumer
consumer complaints against the company
and i read through them and
more people were talking about these
safety issues and other issues like them
billing
people's credit cards without their
consent and then
you know my very last day on stanford
campus my sophomore year i published
this big report criticizing the company
safety practices
and that got some attention and i sent
it to a bunch of journalists
one of whom worked at the wall street
journal and then the wall street journal
started looking into it and nine months
later they published
a front page story on care.com safety
issues
and then after that the ceo see a phone
general counsel the company resigned
um the stock ended up falling and was
acquired by iac
and this wasn't mentioned in the
institutional investor piece but the
company even sent the private
investigator to my house like i wasn't
home i was in college but
my parents were home when a private
investigator showed up by
this company um but but the the end
point is that
the cool thing about this activist short
selling or trying to expose wrongdoing
is unlike long investing where you're
kind of buying and selling pieces of
paper
you can actually have an impact like
this company is now in better hands with
the company that's taking safety more
seriously
a lot of the executives have resigned
and i'm not sure if that would have been
the case or would have happened as
quickly if like
i and other people didn't write about it
and try to kind of
bring this conduct to the limelight yeah
it's an incredible story from
the sense that one your young kid who
did the work right which i think a lot
of people just aren't willing to do
two you have um kind of this uh skeptic
type perspective right like hey prove it
to me and i just don't believe what you
say on your website
uh and then three is uh you you kind of
have this
almost tenacious nature to get in the
hands of short sellers to get it in the
hands of media and kind of
do the work to distribute it why not
also then profit from all of that work
right so you don't have a fund
you don't have any sort of positions
you're simply writing about it why only
write
not do any investing so usually i don't
take positions care.com at one point in
time i did
have a position against the company i
disclosed that and i ended up even
losing money because the stock didn't
fall
in the time frame i thought it would
fall um
but the thing is markets tend to rise
over time on average
if you look over the last hundred years
the stock market's increased about eight
or nine percent a year
so betting against companies is a really
high hard thing where
even if you're good you might just break
even over the long run because you know
the markets
rise over time like the best short
sellers you know
short only tend to make one or two
percent a year the real benefit of short
selling
is that if you're in a fund you can go
more long
other things and being long is how you
make the real money
um so so so you know
another thing i worry about is if you
take positions you might be seen as less
credible
or you know you're just trying to move
the market
to increase your position um
you know you also need a large base of
capital so maybe in five years
want some better network to know more
people i could see myself launching a
fund that focused on this but when
you're young you want to
learn you want to meet people you want
to network and i think a newsletter is a
great way to
show what you can do and kind of build a
public track record that can then lead
to
a more lucrative thing like a hedge fund
yeah and so one of the other things that
you talked about with care.com is you
filed these 50 basically freedom of
information act requests
how did you know to do that is that a
common practice like talk to me a little
bit about how you get a lot of the
information that
maybe isn't just available via a simple
google search or in the public filings
that the company files
that's a great question and i think this
is the best kept secret in the
investment community
um the freedom of information act means
that
anybody individuals can request public
government records
um from the government the typical way
people do it is they'll go to a federal
agency like the ftc
and a hedge fund analyst might say give
me all your complaints
against shopify or apple or palantir
because they want to see what are
consumers saying that's bad about the
company
and could this be an investment risk
that's unknown
what i do that's a little different and
almost no one does this for whatever
reason i find it really odd
is i'll go to like the state level to
state attorney generals
and usually they'll have like a
dedicated email address or web form
where you can file
public record requests not all states
will fulfill them
but most states will say like hey send
us a request
i say all consumer complaints against
xyz company within the last three years
and some states will turn around two
weeks later and just like send you an
email pdf
with all these consumer complaints
against companies and the reason these
complaints are so nice is you can
literally see
handwritten complaints by people who go
to the attorney general's office
to like complain about a company you can
see letters that people have mailed in
you can oftentimes see um the attorney
general writing letters to companies and
the company's responses
and if you see a company that's like
repeatedly like paying fines and
restitution to consumers
you know this is probably part of a
broader trend
of them misleading consumers um so
that's kind of what a public record
report
request is and how i use them um
so one of the basic things if anybody
wanted to diligence the company
is i'd say file public record requests
or foia requests for consumer complaints
ideally at the state level and you're
going to get dozens of complaints
against the company and you can read
them
and decide whether a company's acting
ethically or not
so i looked into seaworld at one time
which is a company in florida
i wrote an email to the florida attorney
general's public record officer
and i said could i please have consumer
complaints against this company within
the last three years
sometimes they'll charge you a nominal
fee like five dollars oftentimes it's
nothing
and you'll get these complaints back and
in the case of sea world
most of the complaints seemed frivolous
and the company had good responses and
it didn't seem like there was a big
issue
other times you might see like you might
go to a used car dealership and you'll
see that they're just constantly ripping
off customers they're constantly
promising to reduce customers debt or
like do a return
once the attorney general gets involved
the state attorney general gets involved
and that's a sign that the business
might not be acting as ethically as it
should
and consequently deserves a lower
multiple in the public markets because
a company that delights its customers
and has happy customers
is worth a lot more than a company
that's misleading its customers or
hurting its customers
and isn't going to have that brand
loyalty over time
absolutely and one of the things that is
interesting to me is so again you go and
you do all this work you're
looking at filings you're doing
information request acts all this stuff
and then you're putting it into a
newsletter uh the bear cave tell me
about this
what was the idea around actually
starting a newsletter who's reading it
how are you growing it
what's going on there so the barricade
newsletter i started senior year in
college
just to keep track of other people's
research so
there's maybe 30 or 40 of these activist
short sellers out there sometimes just
individuals doing deep research on
companies
putting a report out on their website or
twitter page and showing the world like
hey you should bet against this company
you should sell stock in this company
they're bad i always had a tough time
keeping track of it and i knew other
hedge fund analysts did too
just because there's so many people
doing it and there's like no uniform
distribution
so i started this newsletter just as a
way to say every week
every monday here's the new activist
short reports people put out last week
and here's a quick recap
of what's going on it started to catch
on with hedge fund analysts so then i
started doing
more work where i would recap the
activist short reports of the week
but i might highlight companies that had
recently switched auditors or
are using a subpar auditor for their
market cap
or have been receiving extra scrutiny
from the sec
through public sec comic letters which
you can find
in the public scc database um and then i
you know i put in more work to hide show
what other people were
writing about and highlight potential
companies
um that are shady and then that just
started to grow
it was growing by about a hundred people
a week and then on october 1st
i decided to launch a paid tier where
for 34
a month twice a month i'll do deep dives
on companies
um you know where i'll look at issues
like executive turnover
changes in revenue recognition policy
sec comment letters
public litigation against the company
and complaints obtained through foia
requests
stuff in that sphere and twice a month
i'll find a company with a lot of red
flags
and do a write-up on it and you know the
target audience is probably hedge fund
analysts that just want to be more
informed about companies in the universe
or
find potential companies to bet against
and start researching
so that's the target audience but i
think it's grown to be just
people who are interested in finance and
fraud and corporate wrongdoing
and just want to learn more about how
these bad companies operate
and how you can research them yeah i
love this
how do you come up with the ideas as to
who to research right there's thousands
of companies that you could look at
how do you know to go look at a sea
world or somebody else
is it you're reading something online
you see something fishy are you looking
in databases is it just you sitting
there saying like hey who do i think is
screwing around
like how do you come up with the ideas
as to where to start your research
so pomp there's a lot of ways i know
you're really active on twitter
i use twitter a lot too there's a lot of
smart
you know finance analysts on twitter if
you can find the right people
and sometimes it's literally just a
tweet somebody sends about a company
you know then what i'll do once i see
just it could be a news article it could
be a tweet it could be somebody
saying something in my ear it's then the
key thing is what do you do in the first
30 minutes to decide if you want to
spend more time on it
i'll quickly look to see if there's a
lot of executive turnover
you know it's not too hard to see um
executive turnover i use a service
called insider score but there's a lot
of ways to do it
and if a company has had like three
different ceos in the last two years
or multiple different cfos that's a red
flag and it'll walk me
and make me want to look into them more
i'll oftentimes look at
who their auditor is and if they're a
big company
but they're using an auditor that's
typically only used by small companies
that could be a red flag that makes me
want to look at it more
um other ways i come up with ideas is i
read
other people's research just on seeking
alpha or value valueinvestorsclub.com
or just put out on twitter and we'll
decide okay
this is interesting it's worth looking
into and the final way
um there's two more ways i sometimes use
screens
so one thing i did is i looked at uh i
got a list of every publicly traded
company
and their auditor and i looked for big
companies that were using auditors not
used by any other company
and there was this company called
celsius holdings it's a billion and a
half dollar company
and i was using an auditor called
assurance dimensions which no other
public
nyse or nasdaq listed company used and
the average market cap of this
auditor clients was like five million
but this one and a half billion dollar
company was using it that's a red flag
and the company ended up having a lot of
other red flags
and then the final thing i do is i go to
the sec's database it's called edgar
and i search for public comment letters
which are letters the sec
sends to companies usually to scrutinize
their financials or disclosures more
there's about 5000 of these or so
released every year so there's a lot
they're released with the 30-day delay
and i read all of them
um most of them are frivolous or like
highlight small issues but once in a
while you'll get a like 10 point comment
letter
and the company won't be giving good
responses like the sec will say why did
you change his disclosure
explain this policy explain this
inconsistency
and sometimes the companies will be like
we're just wrong the number
there was a misprint you know there was
a there was a typographical error by a
secretary and if you see a lot of those
then it's a sign oh maybe this company's
got more typographical errors somewhere
um
so it's a lot of different sources
twitter's a great way value investors
club seeking alpha
you know the scc's database it comes
from a lot of places my ideas
i i love the the misprint and the
typographical error i make those all the
time
uh no problem um the last thing i want
to talk to you about
is uh is probably the biggest um kind of
fraud case or tax evasion case
uh robert smith obviously and this
equity partners
it's pretty well documented i think what
robert himself has faced
but it sounds like maybe you think there
may be other problems at vista equity
talk to me kind of just about how you
think about that situation and any other
things you're thinking about there
so this is a great example where i think
the media is kind of focusing the
spotlight on the wrong thing so
robert smith is a very wealthy private
equity co-founder of
vista equity partners he got he paid
about a 200 million dollar
fine to settle charges of tax evasion
um and it looked like he was potentially
going to go to jail before he signed
this non-prosecution agreement so
big red flag the media's covered that a
lot
but there's like a lot of other issues
that the media is just like
not looking at but it's not that hard to
find
so he's really close with this other
businessman from the austin texas area
named nate paul who is this real estate
developer and if you look back
in old articles you'll see that they
were friends that
robert smith invested in this guy's fund
and was praising him
there's photos of them together they
were close
and then this guy nate paul has also
been raided by the fbi last year he's
part of an ongoing scandal
at the texas attorney general's office
you know
he's in bankruptcy or has declared
bankruptcy for some of his companies
and like he's going to be the reason
that the texas attorney general resigned
and like he paid bribes and
allegedly did illicit donations um
hired the texas ag's girlfriend to cover
up an affair
so this guy nate paul did all this
wrongdoing robert smith did all his
wrongdoing
but they're friends and that's like
another big data point
that robert smith was like involved in
bad stuff
they both got money from the government
when robert some of robert smith's
companies
um got got money from my texas
enterprise fund for taking jobs in state
there's just like a lot of this
wrongdoing and it's like you know if you
only highlight one incident some people
might say oh this is an isolated
incident robert smith was misled
but if you show there's like a pattern
of this wrongdoing
um people are a lot more skeptical on
vista too
like portfolio companies have sued vista
saying that they're mismarking the
assets
and presented what i think is compelling
evidence but the wall street journal in
new york times doesn't talk about
that there's like a lot of evidence of
like huge like
you know issues at vista like miss
marking assets
lawsuits from portfolio companies
associations with other people being
raided by the fbi the co-founders
leaving
like but no one's putting it together
everybody's the media is just so focused
on this tax fraud thing
it's like i bet dollars to donuts that
this thing becomes a bigger issue maybe
in three or six months
but people just aren't thinking about it
in the right way in my opinion and
that's something i've been talking about
in the barricade newsletter too
huh are you gonna do like a deep dive
report on that one
so i i've done like three mini deep
dives i i'm working on it
the thing that makes this a little
tougher is i'm really document based i
like reading documents
sometimes there's a limit to how far you
can get by just reading lawsuits
and filing public record requests you
know sometimes like you know you the
only way you can really progress the
story is by like
going out and you know cold emailing
ex-employees and
uh sometimes i feel bad if you're just
getting too aggressive so i might
i might do more on that but part of me
thinks that i'm like kind of at the
limit of what i can get
document based and like when you take it
to the next level of like
you know cold calling cold emailing
current and former employees you can
risk a compliance concern of getting
material info on a company you can also
risk getting sued or
you just you just being a little too
aggressive for somebody who's
writing a newsletter so i'm not sure how
far i'll go on it but i definitely think
there's a lot more issues to come out at
used to equity partners interesting
anything else that you're looking at
right now that you think is uh
is worth noting or um kind of other red
flags with other companies that you're
saying hey
you know here's kind of a thought
process that i think could become a much
bigger issue in the next three to six
months
one person who i think is just
outstanding at highlighting these issues
when they're small before they get big
is a guy named marco hodes he's active
on twitter at alder lane eggs
there was a company called my medics
that made health care products he called
the ceo of fraud and two years later
it turns out the company was inflating
sales by
bribing doctors and like you know
asking the government to over purchase
product that wasn't going to be used
so he had one really successful campaign
two years ago
now he's being critical of a company
called um
penumbra which makes catheters for old
people
and the thing is like this company 10
billion dollar company that makes his
healthcare equipment and catheters
their their products have been linked to
these 17 deaths
and my under basic understanding is that
their products have been pulled from
europe and japan or at least parts of
there
um but they're still available in the
u.s and the companies near all-time
highs
um there was another person named
gabrielle grego who wrote a detailed
40-page report
on the company's concerns on the
company's issues but the stock hasn't
really moved that much so so penumbra is
one that i'm watching
and it seems like with a lot of these
active short reports is you can put out
really good content the stock won't move
and people will ignore it and move on
or you can put out mediocre content the
stock will move and everybody will think
it's great
um this is one where i think the
content's been really good the problems
highlighted have been really serious at
penumbra
but the market isn't paying enough
attention yet so that that's one i've
got on my watch list
yeah that's awesome what's your plans
for uh the bear cave let's finish up
there with uh kind of
what are you thinking in terms of how
you're gonna grow this or what you
wanted to grow into
you know so so right now it's a paid
newsletter it's doing well financially
i'm probably gonna just
keep growing the free list and keep
going growing the paid list
um newsletter economics are really nice
it's kind of what i've been learning you
know you get paid cash upfront and
people buy an annual subscription the
retention rates tend to be really high
you know if it grows to be 10 times the
size the amount of work i need to put in
is still about the same so you can earn
a lot
doing the same amount of work um my best
guess
is that i do this for two or three more
years and maybe launch
other financial newsletters i think
there's a big market for
paid newsletters i know your wife runs a
really successful one
i think particularly in the finance
space these people in finance have a lot
of money and are happy to pay for
research
there can be a lot more paid newsletters
so my plan is just to grow it
organically
keep trying to put out good insightful
research on companies
and maybe down the road start two or
three different ones
the go the goal will never be to be like
the morning brew which is like not
as much depth but it's more for a mass
audience i think i'll always focus on
like more of the
hedge fund analyst proud but um
i could see myself branching out to not
just highlighting problems
at companies but maybe highlighting
interesting companies that could
potentially be worth investing in
or like looking at insider buys at a
company or like when new
interesting board members are added
highlighting that i i i think there's a
big market for these paid newsletters
and i'm really bullish on that space i
love it
uh i asked the same two questions
everyone before i wrap up and then
you'll get to ask me one
uh the first is what's the most
important book you've ever read
oh gosh um it's hard to live
to to take it to one um
one of my favorites is bad blood by john
kerry
so he was a wall street journal reporter
that kind of broke the theranos
story and did all the reporting to take
it down and then because of that
he could he wrote a really detailed
great book
on theranos so even though the company
was never publicly traded
you got a really good sense of how these
you know exaggerated unethical companies
can behave and get away with so much
so in their noses cases they had like
really high profile board members who
gave them credibility
um so so so
that that that's a book i really like
bad blood by john kerry
i've read that one it is fantastic
second question is aliens are you a
believer or non-believer
it depends how you define aliens life
outside like our solar system
yes are they gonna look like us or like
maybe be in a way we can even comprehend
like
maybe not i like that answer i feel like
uh
intelligent life somewhere else is very
likely what shape or form
i'll leave that to the scientists right
i like that um so now i get to ask one
to you
you get asked me one question what you
got for me okay so you're a big bitcoin
bull
i know there's a lot of people in the
finance community who are a little more
skeptical
you know what makes you so confident and
what do you think are the biggest risks
that five years from now bitcoin could
be at zero
or like potentially worthless like what
what what could what could happen
that could destroy the both thesis here
yeah so it's a great question um
i think my confidence is just i've done
the work right i've really kind of
spent the time energy uh an effort to
go through what are all the things that
are happening what's not
happening kind of what are all the
different thesis which ones do i think
check out which ones don't which ones
are strong which ones are weak
and so for that i also think that
in order to have a high degree of
confidence in a bowl case you better
have a
good articulation of what the bear case
would be right which is basically your
question
um and so for me it's you know if you
look at it from a pure
what does bitcoin ultimately hope to be
but yet has not yet
achieved you can talk about the actual
like electronic cash
so bitcoin has served as a great store
of value over long periods of time
in short periods of time because of the
volatility it makes it really really
hard to consider it
a store of value you know if i buy it
today uh for twenty thousand dollars and
then it drops tomorrow to eighteen
thousand dollars that doesn't really fit
the the store
value narrative over long periods of
time though it's been fantastic right
it's actually protected your wealth
better than any other asset in the world
so i think that's one piece is kind of
the short term
uh viewpoint of store value and medium
of exchange
uh has not happened yet i think the bold
case for that is like
in the evolution of technology and money
that happens later on in the life cycle
of a new money but
definitely has not happened yet so if
you don't believe it's going to happen
like that's a pretty strong thing to
hang your hat on
the second thing i think is um there's
always the risk of a self-inflicted
wound and what i mean by that is
there's a bug that's introduced into the
code there's some sort of
issue in terms of this is a piece of
technology it does have software code
and it is reliant on kind of the
continued upkeep and operations of that
code
and so uh there's not been issues yet in
terms of anything that's been fatal
but again part of the i think bear
thesis would be like
how in the world is it that you'll go
forever without introducing a fatal bug
right again i i personally don't buy
into that but i think that's a strong
um uh kind of argument for a bear to
make the third thing is about like
geopolitical cooperation right
is a lot of people would um kind of the
intellectually lazy argument is oh the
united states is going to ban it or oh
china is going to ban it but only one
country trying to ban a decentralized
asset doesn't really have any impact
because all the value just flows to
the other people in the world who are
going to adopt or use that asset
what you need is you need actual
geopolitical cooperation of
let's say the major kind of superpowers
all working together to try to ban it
right then you can have a much more kind
of generous
um and material impact on the asset than
if just one country has it and so
uh if i was kind of arguing the bear
thesis i would say oh of course all the
you know
uh leaders of these countries are gonna
call each other up and they're all gonna
work together and ban it
now the reason why i'm a bull is because
i don't think that that's gonna happen
right i think that's very unlikely
actually uh but i think that's another
piece
uh and then another part of this kind of
bear thesis is all of the
kind of regulatory um kind of edges i'll
call them right so things like there's
no de minimis exemption for when you use
bitcoin in a transaction you have to pay
tax on that
and so that provides a bunch of friction
now the bulls will argue that that
eventually de minimis uh exemption will
get
uh applied the bears will argue no it
won't and therefore that'll
be a huge kind of detraction for it ever
being used as an actual currency
and so i think that like you can go on
and on and on and as you can hear like
that's just a couple at the top of my
head there's probably 20 or 30 other
issues that i think
you know i've got a decent understanding
of the bear case but i
kind of fall into the bull camp on and i
think that's actually really really
important when you have high conviction
is
if you can't argue the other side if you
can't articulate the other side of it
then i think that you've got a really
question like did i do the work
right and if you can do that then it
almost gives you more confidence and
conviction
in whichever side of the argument that
you ended up on right if you know you
did the work
sure you can be wrong but at least
you're not going to be wrong
because you didn't do the work you're
just wrong because your conclusion on
the work was inaccurate
right yeah huh no that's that's great
are you a bitcoin believer or not
sorry are you a bitcoin bull or no
uh i i probably i don't own any but it
it's interesting and i i'm a bull but
not
with the same enthusiasm you are that's
fine
beat a bull as being a bull
i love it all right everyone where can
we send people to sign up for
uh bear cave and where can they find you
on the internet just google the bear
cave newsletter it'll come up
it's thebearcave.substack.com but just
get google the bear cave newsletter
and i'm on twitter um edwin dorsey that
my handle is at stock jabber
but if you just google edwin dorsey in
the bear cave my twitter and the
barricade newsletter will
pop up awesome man well listen thank you
so much for taking the time to do this
i i read the institutional investor
article and i said i got to talk to that
guy that guy sounds interesting
so i hope i hope people enjoy this as
well tom thanks so much for doing this
really enjoyed it